für Kinder
Empfehlung beendet ja das ist ja schön
wenn Sie das jetzt beenden aber sie
hätten eigentlich diese Empfehlung gar
nie aussprechen dürfen meiner Meinung
nach denn es war wurde ziemlich früh
deutlich dass das Kinder in der Regel
also überhaupt nicht schwer erkranken
und dass sie auch gar nicht Treiber
dieser Pandemie sind und dass sie auch
nicht diese Gefahr darstellen für
vulnerable Personen also alte kranke
Menschen als dies dies eben dargestellt
wurde und da haben auch Personen wie
Herr Lauterbach oder ähm Herr Damen und
andere haben da ihren Anteil daran dass
sozusagen auch die die STIKO massiv
Druck also das auf Sie Druck ausgeübt
wurde um solche Empfehlungen dann eben
auch auszusprechen